dieses urteil könnte jetzt richtig teuer
werden für viele versicherungen in
deutschland die versicherungskammer
bayern muss einem münchner biergarten
betreiber jetzt eine millionensumme
dafür zahlen dass er aufgrund der korona
pandemie seinen biergarten lange
schließen musste das landgericht münchen
verurteilte die öffentliche versicherung
heute zu einer zahlung von 1,01
millionen euro weil christian vogler
sein augustiner keller
jetzt also solange nicht offen haben
konnte was wird das für konsequenzen
jetzt in ganz deutschland haben darüber
möchte ich sprechen jetzt und zwar mit
dem anwalt von christian vogler
sagen sie uns als allererstes wie schwer
war es jetzt diesen erfolg vor gericht
zu erzielen
also ja jemand welche signalwirkung wird
von diesem urteil heute außerdem die
klare erkenntnis dass man als
versicherer das versprechen halten muss
wenn man absicherung gegen solchen gegen
viren die sich massenhaft verbreiteten
versprochen hat und das gericht sprach
heute davon
das verdikt das klausel werk des
versicherers sei intransparent
das gesetz hat sich fortlaufend
weiterentwickelt zu den krankheiten und
viren die erfasst sind die versicherer
haben über viele jahre nichts geändert
und dieses auseinanderfallen
zwischenstaatlichen ordnungsrahmen und
privaten versicherungsvertrag hat das
gericht nicht billigen wollen und ich
bin dankbar dass das gericht mit großer
sorgfalt an die sache rangegangen ist
die verhandlung im ende juli hat über
100 minuten gedauert dann sieht man mit
wie viel herzblut das gericht daran
gegangen ist und das ergebnis spricht
für sich
das ist nicht der kern der sache sind
auch einer der anwälte von herrn vogel
hat ihr mandant das urteil aufgenommen
und wann wird das geld fließen
der vogel war natürlich sehr erfreut
denn er hat ihm wurden im vorfeld ja 15
prozent angeboten und das noch
gnadenhalber mit dem argument
eigentlich müssten sie gar nicht haften
außerdem bekommen käme er 70 prozent von
staatlichen leistungen die
kurzarbeitergeld oder sonst was diese
argumente hat das gericht alle
zerpflückt und insofern ist das
natürlich ein riesenfortschritt ob ich
statt knapp 200.000 eben eine million
bekommen und so sieht das sehr vielen
und die frage wann das geld fließt ist
natürlich jetzt so leicht nicht zu
beantworten also wir gehen mit an
sicherheit grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit
davon aus dass hier berufung zum
fünfundzwanzigsten senat am olg münchen
eingelegt wird darüber hinaus gebe es
noch eine revision theoretisch aber
vielleicht gibt es ja auch einen
politischen druck oder irgendeine andere
geschichte die sagt es ist vielleicht
nicht so klug jetzt hier weiterhin auf
alter alten argumenten zu beharren die
jetzt hier von den gerichten zunächst
hier in beim lg münchen 1 sorgfältig
zerpflückt worden und lasse mich sehr
freuen wenn man das urteil hat ja vor
allem konsequenzen für die
versicherungen wg milliarden müssen
jetzt bezahlt der gesamtverband der
rasmussen der ist da seid erster april
witzigerweise diesen jahres in der
geschäftsführungsebene tätig hat ende
april mitgeteilt es gebe etwa 73.000
versicherungsverträge und er hat damals
gesagt ein großteil habe keine pandemie
sicherung ein kleinerer teil schon auf
meine anfrage im august konnte aber dann
nicht mehr erklären nach welchen
kriterien mehr unterschieden hat klar
ist dass der gesamtverband der deutschen
versicherungswirtschaft derzeit in den
letzten zügen daran ist für die
betriebsschließung versicherung ein
neues klausel werk als muster dann für
die ganze branche zu entwickeln
einige versicherer kommen jetzt mit
neuen texten auch raus da wird pandemie
definitiv nicht mehr dabei sein
sicher ist es ist auf alle fälle ein
urteil mit großer signalwirkung für
deutschlands gastwirte vielen dank an
stephan kürthy unseren kollegen in
münchen und wir konnten nach dem urteil
auch mit christian kohler also dem wirt
selber sprechen darüber was für eine
signalwirkung in seinen augen dieses
urteil jetzt also hat
die genetischen rechtsanwälte haben
gesagt ja das ist ja alles um drogen
anfangen das werden wir die gewinner
sind im unrecht und es braucht keine
klagen die haie auf diese 15 prozent
regelung gerade jetzt aber ist endlich
mal richter da er auch sagt ein das
unrecht was ihr macht ja es gibt das ein
spiegel interview von komplette von der
allianz der sagt wenn ein dritter sagen
würde dass wir bezahlen müssen dann
zahlen wir natürlich packt das uns
verwandt das war seine aussage
jetzt hat er diesen dritten der das
gesagt hat haben wir reagiert
das ist ja so wie gesagt es geht um die
existenz von vom betrieb müssen ja
vermitteln gingen mit einem kinderheim
mit am herd ist einfach nicht vergessen
da geht es wirklich so ist dann kannst
du bist so gut geht man also jetzt ganz
ehrlich gesprochen
es gibt wirklich und die kollegen die in
dem rücken zur wand steht mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schaue ich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren